yo this is mr. Family Ties aka that Joe
album in stores December 6 I am here
with $15 to pick my all-time MIG squad
let's get it baby this is fried you're
gonna make him ready
we're gonna pick patch of new patches
the greatest Nick ever played it's just
the bottom line you know I'm saying
ain't nobody stronger than Pat
now I'm gonna give you four that makes
it nine dollars make it rain go with
Bernard King cuz he's the greatest next
player of all time do you know that man
was scoring 16 points a game 70 point
disrespect [ __ ] he was doing out
there on that Court
man's 1/2 an hour to go and so now we
got Pat we got Bernard King I'm giving
you this way I'm getting jammed up that
I'm giving you three going with star
berry so I got stuck questionable I know
some people would have went Mark Jackson
but I'm going Patrick Ewing
I'm going Bernard King and I got a star
belly this is the only difference you
could have said I want star berrykin
star berry is one of the most underrated
players of all time
[Applause]
I don't really know about this error
like that but from everything I heard
two dollars I'm going Bill Bradley for
rain name recognition because I wasn't
definitely not going in I loved him they
believe porzingis or RJ or Richard Gere
and I'm I'm gonna go for Bill Bradley of
what I've heard of when he used to play
I don't I didn't see much film Bradley
GABA left a pastor Bradley jump shot
that side now with the one buckaroo uh
uh one dollar
grandmama Larry Jones and that's not 15
that's that shot that clutch clutch shot
11:09 ten seconds to go Johnson is
three-point territory but gone
Junction [ __ ] up now players are women
that we Johnson made that shot to win
the game then the whole place is at the
same time like you know thirty that
night was crazy what up y'all this Fat
Joe this is my all-time mixed water
right here
family ties December 6 let's get it